on a eu la loi veil qui permet donc le
fait d'avoir une interruption volontaire
de grossesse
mais ce n'était pas vraiment une loi
pour tout en fait comme elle a été
obtenue dans un contexte très contraint
très particulier le délai était alors à
12 semaines à 10 semaines maman il est à
12 comme on a l'un des délais parmi les
délais les plus bas d'europe et beaucoup
de pays voisins qui permettent le
recours à l'ivg et jusqu'à 18 22
semaines
eh ben on se retrouve avec en moyenne
5000 femmes qui vivent en france et qui
doivent avorter à l'étranger à leurs
frais je sais pas si c'est le bon délai
je pense c'est quand j'ai l'impression
que ces sujets de débattre délais sont
plus des prétextes
si je veux pas prendre votre place
discussions me trompe à bout dit qu'un
certain nombre de femmes qui vont avoir
à l'étranger parce que les délais en
france en douce au mètre carré tandis
que l'on espère qu à quatre semaines
ensuite à 18 2 euros et menu jusqu'à 24
et parce qu'elles peuvent pas apporter
parce que il y a des problèmes de
structure est passé de structures nous
les déserts médicaux
on sait qu'on a vu dans ses pas
uniquement sur un portement et donc
comme maison il n'ya pas de place
partout elle dépasse les délais et là
pendant les débats qui a eu l assemblée
beaucoup de mecs henry la parole et
notamment le conseil de l'ordre des
médecins en expliquant que ont déjà
salée par jour le problème demande
future mais qu'en plus elle est allée
voir des médecins kinés euros qui
refuseront qui pratiquent encore que
l'hérault faisons le père donc c'est
pour ça que je dis que c'est un prétexte
je pense que l'on n'est plus dans une
fin de course et fletcher et surtout
loin n'intègre pas la formation l ivg
instrumental aux études médicales et
gynécologiques
ce qui nous confronte à une pénurie
croissante de professionnels formés donc
on a une tendance déjà sur proposer une
ivg médicamenteuses qui décale comme je
l'étais à cinq semaines et ce qui va
priver bon nombre de femmes du choix de
la méthode
la première question et on le dit
d'ailleurs dans le
vos manifeste des 343 dont je suis
signataire qui a lancé par le planning
familial qu'il ya une grande structure
qui est absolument sur tous les
territoires et qui est bien au fait de
ces questions là et puis avec les lois
de restructuration de l'hôpital public
on a eu un problème qui favorise ici les
dépassements de délais c'est que c'était
la loi fameuse loi hpst sous madame
bachelot dont sous sarkozy il ya eu
plein de petits hôpitaux de proximité
qui ont fermé avec leur maternité avec
leurs centres ivg et donc ça a créé des
grandes inégalités d'accès à ces
services selon les territoires parce que
moi il ya deux centres ivg va plus la
queue s'allonge et plus on risque de
dépasser des délais est donc l'un des
femmes qui s'y prennent absolument
attendre se retrouve à dépasser ces
dites moi ce qui me dérange un peu dans
ces sujets là c'est keith a refusé de
sûreté publique globale qui est un sujet
qui est très important c'est un sujet
qui est qui est très délicat et je
trouve que ce sujet là et donc trop
vidéo le juger pour leur entraînement et
notamment la panique en fait non je ne
vais pas me logique en refusant la sspa
différents dossiers chauds des 24
adhérents si vous voulez je ne fais pas
l'idéologie forcément je le cherchais
des faits et les faits c'est par exemple
je connais des personnes qui sont contre
l'avortement général quand on les
appelle et quand d'ailleurs des grands
journalistes dans leur merci comme
biomasse etc
les appels pour les continents vois que
vous êtes plutôt adepte de fil qui
nuance que des frais moi je suis
journaliste donc je sais pas moi qui
fais des centres d'appels moi par contre
j'ai des personnes qui est qui qui ont
été wayne qui ont eu les centres
d'appels qui ont appelé les centres
d'appels et notamment les centres
d'appels numéro vert famille en mauvais
qu'ils ont été dans les centres de
planification et non event à bio qui
m'ont tapé italia qui m'ont raconté
comment ça s'est passé
moi je relate des faits ensuite vous
parlez des blues mais si on va sur le
site ebay peut ambitionner tout bêtement
savoir comment ça fonctionne ivg point
vous explique qu'il faut quelques sites
officiels du gouvernement qui explique
qu'il ya des défaites 12 partout il faut
faire attention aux faux numéro et qui
expliquent noir sur blanc que iliad et
qu'il faut pas prêter attention aux
soi-disant de complications est
traumatisme et l'avortement
pardon j'ai témoignages de familles
expliquent elles ont eu des trucs tout
le monde en a eu en jeu pour la forme et
pillages ont eu des traumatismes et des
complications et vous êtes sur le site
officiel du gouvernement qui explique et
un sou des soi-disant complications ce
n'est pas moi je la fais selon laquelle
dans les numéros des coudes pour le coup
idéologique et contre l'avortement
on met en garde les femmes en disant
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont faits soit disons
match mais elle voit venir et on m'a dit
et après tout un tas d'expériences dans
la vie peut être mal vécue mais là vous
parlez dans un pays voici les faits
remontent à l'expérience de l'avortement
et je ne pouvais plus d'utiliser de tels
faits qui nous parce que les femmes sauf
parfaitement part dans sa vie que l'on
peut très bien vivre
d'accord je parle je ne refuse pas de
légumes ou encore une fois je vais
chercher les informations raison et
qu'on raconte sur le site ivg point
banque qui est sûr le premier titre sur
lequel on tend quand on veut se
renseigner et qu'on parle de soi disant
de complications et de traumatismes moi
ça m'a l'air quels sont les soi-disant
complications des témoignages de femmes
qui me disent que je roulais traumatisme
des complications document dit non ça
veut dire que les témoignages de femmes
sont des menteuses elles mentent pas ce
que c'est les complications et
chromatique n'existe pas